the Counter-Strike 2 Limited Test is
really starting to ramp up after what
felt like ages of just non-stop dust 2
has evolved into a new host of maps and
features but with every new update comes
a new set of bugs and glitches and
honestly they're as funny as they are
intriguing
but the question Still Remains is the
game actually getting better and are we
going to get our hands on it sometime
this summer well to get a better idea of
what's going on I spoke with cs2's
greatest beta tester
[Music]
alrighty folks before we get into it I
wanted to let you all know that we have
a brand new episode of into the dark
coming out this weekend we've made into
the dark in partnership with crack and
rum it's a unique dive into the
incredible stories behind Gaming's
biggest protagonists as they took a leap
into the unknown and emerged Victorious
with this newest episode focusing on
prey's inFamous Ash Arrow at Worlds
2016. check out the link below now
before we even start I need to preface
this video because I already know you
are in the comments yes I know the
entire point of a beta is to stress test
these servers and find bugs I get it but
Counter-Strike 2 is not your usual game
it's a goddamn worldwide phenomenon and
every inch of this beta needs to be
dissected I also have nothing better to
do so allow it anyway if you're like me
and you love seeing how video games are
made when you heard that CS2 was going
to have its own Limited Test you would
have been ecstatic and a bit surprised
sure CS go had its own beta back in 2012
but you have to admit that the internet
is a lot different now than it was back
that so valve a notoriously tight-lipped
company giving access to people to not
only watch but participate in the
sausage being made was a bold Choice
especially given the state the game was
in because at first it wasn't exactly
pretty I mean visually the game was
looking great but there were a ton of
crazy ass bugs that came with it oh my
God whoa whoa whoa
what the
what's on fire
Okay so
do I press e wait oh I did it I did it
it just said at the bottom of my screen
when I died you picked up an AK Red Line
wait let's see if I have an AK Red Line
yeah
however flaming knives and automatic
Scouts were just the tip of the iceberg
as the beta went on the bugs only got
more bizarre I swear to God if this
crashes my okay what
wait
we can't tell anybody about this what is
this Shady the command Works what now
this one in particular raised a lot of
eyebrows and even sparked some
conspiracy theories some thought that
allowing players to turn on wall hacks
was Val's way of sussing out potential
hackers in reality it was probably just
a Dev tool that they forgot to remove
but nevertheless it was very funny and
you don't see that in betas every day
but all of these silly bugs weren't that
big of a deal they're easily fixable and
honestly speaking valve had bigger
problems on their hands there were some
serious issues that sparked concern
amongst play testers and die hard fans
of the franchise so I sat down and had a
chat with any content creator JoJo who
had been grinding the beta more than
anyone else I can think of and although
he was enjoying himself he expressed
that there were fundamental aspects of
the game that just didn't feel right if
you have high ping it feels really bad
like the interp settings or the netcode
or something still feels kind of bad
which is like worrisome because that's a
pretty like important thing I don't know
it's just it's a massive reason why I
still play the game like the movement of
Cs is just like unmatched uh I think
bunny hopping is still not as good as it
like it's supposed to be like it's still
like super inconsistent to hit the Hops
I think everyone I've talked to would
like say the same JoJo wasn't the only
one either eventually people started
getting bored and dissatisfied with the
Limited Test and to be fair there's only
so much dust too one can take but on top
of all that the bugs movement issues and
latency problems weren't giving people a
reason to stick around and without any
Assurance from valve that things were
going to get better people like myself
feared that maybe CS2 wasn't even close
to being done however after two months
of radio silence the CS2 beta finally
started getting updates on top of the
host of new features and Bug fixes dust
2 was finally gone and players were
given a chance to test out Mirage but
with a new map came a lot more problems
and let's just say our pal JoJo grinding
non-stop as usual God bless him
unintentionally became the master of
pushing CS2 to its Breaking Point
clip this also
flip this also
there we go
I love your vision it's really good here
I'm smoked off
now although JoJo won't take credit for
discovering these bugs I will argue that
he is the one to perfect them whether he
was terrorizing people from the skies or
underneath the floors JoJo's viral Clips
were doing wonders at highlighting the
evolution of CS2 it has his experiences
with the game continued JoJo didn't just
find the clips funny he started to want
to know why they were happening the wall
bangs on Dust two were like the first
thing I like found that was just kind of
broken
like you could just wall bang like
basically it ignores like the last
object it's going through it only counts
like the starting material
so if you start wall banging like a wood
pillar and then there's a concrete wall
behind it it'll just ignore the concrete
wall so it'll only count as well banging
a wood filler which is still like still
happens on nuke and since Counter-Strike
2 is not your average game as his
experiences with the beta continued the
bugs weren't just funny he just like the
rest of us wanted to know why the hell
they were happening now with the update
that brought us nuke a ton of these
silly glitches were obviously solved
that being said valve hasn't fully
solved the whole wall bang issue yet and
once again a new map brings new issues
new issues that Jojo and other CS die
hards are going to find out and show to
the world it's just unclear whether
valve appreciates all the effort or not
uh it's kind of weird they did
in the dust 2 part of the beta they
followed me which I thought was really
cool but then they unfollowed me but
once again all of these bizarre bugs are
just the Growing Pains of making a game
if you've ever participated in a beta
before you'd know the important question
is if those fundamentals movement
latency Etc are actually getting better
and if each new update is bringing us
closer to a full launch this summer I
was super worried that it was just them
they would not care about making the
movement as good as CS go but it does
seem like they do care because they're
still trying to like tweak it and figure
it out of them releasing in the summer
I'd say it's probably like a 40 like
it's possible but they like we haven't
even tested like half the maps yet
of like active duty Maps
and I just don't think that's happening
by the summer now whether or not you
think valve is going to miss yet another
projected release date is a moot point
we actually have no idea how far along
they are in this process who knows what
we're getting could only be a fraction
of what they already have prepared maybe
valvetime is in full effect but you
can't deny that this entire beta
experience whether you participated in
it firsthand or vicariously has been
very interesting valve has been
communicating more in the last four
months than they have in the last 20
years sure it's mostly memes from the
office and patch notes but still this is
very different Behavior than what we're
used to they're actually active and
seemingly listening as I said the
Counter-Strike franchise has had betas
in the past but never this viral and
it's not like CS go ever had any public
test servers every update valve has gets
QA by themselves internally but now even
the smallest change is dissected in real
time by the whole Community listen maybe
I'm being a bit overly sentimental but
it kind of feels like we're all
participating in the creation of
counter-strike's next era
even if most of us can't actually play
it
this JoJo guy deserves a service medal
from valve not only finding the bugs but
even grinding the beta back when it was
just dust two for like two months 15
hours a day this gets crazy he deserves
to be on their payroll but instead they
like unfollowed him and are saying
they're going to revoke his account and
give it to Cooper